ground zero for the supply chain crisis
is as we've been talking about the
nation's ports the port of long beach
and los angeles are choke points as
dozens of cargo ships will have to wait
weeks at sea before they can dock and
unload their products national
correspondent william lachaness is at
the port tonight good evening william
well brett basically the pipeline of
goods from china to the u.s consumer is
running at the pace of a turtle right
now there are a million containers
offshore and waiting to be offloaded and
i am told 90 percent are likely
christmas presents
i just know that there's a huge demand
for truckers right now so i decided to
just put my foot in the door a door that
pays 50 thousand dollars a year to start
as trucking schools get asked every day
for new drivers the backup of ships in
in the ocean waiting to be
unloaded
is really because they don't have the
drivers to
take off the goods 58 ships are anchored
off the ports of la and long beach
waiting weeks to offload their cargo
part of the president's solution is
adding another shift of longshoremen and
opening the ports to truckers from 3 to
7 a.m when you consider the supply chain
it's a system of systems and the only
way you're going to see efficiencies and
fluidity across the system is if every
segment supply chain realigns and we're
taking the first step port officials say
every segment of the supply chain must
work or none of it will without the
warehouse space truckers are also
paralyzed just like the ports today the
white house said major freight haulers
ups and fedex and retailers like home
depot and walmart agreed to utilize the
night shift relieving some pressure on
the port by taking the lead they will
demonstrate
how valuable these nighttime operations
can be and how critically important they
are especially right now in this crisis
that crisis includes inflation consumer
prices moving at a 13-year high climbed
5.4 percent higher than the 2 percent
target set by the federal reserve
nevertheless treasury secretary janet
yellen insists higher prices are
transitory
as for the truck school students they're
preparing for a lifetime of work a lot
of these big truck companies have the
401ks medical dental
vision everything
so the white house says this is more
than a band-aid and port officials here
hope this will trigger a permanent
change to 24 7 but don't expect results
overnight
your present good chance is going to be
on back order or brett you might just
get a gift card back to you maybe so
william thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else